so useful is easy to cook on TV there's  talented producers that can edit errs  and there's all sorts of things that  make you look good  you know before any TV came anywhere  near my career I've mastered my craft  you'll see a side to me across this  class that I don't think has ever been  shown before  nice skills the basics are so important  three fingers down and this beautiful  knuckle is the guiding light across that  knife cooking salmon so the secret is to  score the skin that stops the fish from  buckling up you can't pick up the  world's best cookbook and understand you  need to do it  mmm delicious everything I've learned  understood stolen perfected is laid bare  across this master class for the first  time ever you had learn how to cook  those ingredients from start to finish  I've just spent the last 30 years  busting my ass off to get on the plate  what I'm about to show you and watch but  watch and carefully  I'm gone Ramsey and this is my master  class  you